yeah hello so I'm going to talk a bit
can you hear me okay
microphones are good okay yeah so today
I'm going to talk about a bit about
search it's nice to be black back in
Bloomberg cuz I did work here originally
about three years ago so yeah Who am I
Who am I I'm Eddie
I run the data science team there's
about eight of us at the moment if you
include interns and the sort of things
were interested in a search and
recommendations analytics or sorts of
classification problems centered around
fashion data so who's list if you
haven't if you don't know us we're
basically like a fashion aggregator we
scrape the web we collect loads of
information about fashion products and
then we sell them to our end users so
our business model is essentially taking
this stream of semi structured fashion
data and turning into structured data so
you can present it to the users and sell
them clothes basically so a couple of
little stats about us we scrape about
somewhere around 4 million items every
single day and that's about 50k new
products each day we get on site so one
thing we really have to watch out for
when we're doing anything with data is
we need to automate everything because
we got so many new products you can't
really use people to do anything with
them for example a lot of high end
fashion retailers would manually write
descriptions or manually say this
product is blue but we can't do any of
that we have to do it or with machine
learning instead ok so search so like I
said we scrape all our data searching
that scrape data is really critical to
us it's we use our search algorithm for
all our ads as well and our ad this is
basically how we make money so the
search algorithm needs to be very good
but we don't have control over the data
so we need to very robust algorithms
that can handle these heterogeneous
heterogeneous data so I think search is
quite hard for a number of reasons if
you think of a lot of data science
projects you have things like
recommendation and in red
Commendation you're mapping some finite
set of objects another finite set of
objects so you might be recommending
products based on products so you might
be recommending products based on users
for example so you've got these finite
maps or if you think of a classification
task you're generally mapping to some
very small finite set of categories like
it could be a cat is it a cat for a dog
is mapping to two categories
I think search is especially hard
because you've got an infinite set of
strings and you're trying to flatten to
a finite set of categories so that the
input is very broad I think also is this
problem with around expectations google
has ruined search for the rest of us
like no matter how good your search is
it's never gonna be as good as Google
Google made like the magical and
everyday experience and you've got to
try and compete with that which is quite
hard and the main problem with search is
like what what is a good result what is
relevant you need to try and understand
this and the only way to really
understand it
understand that is through users you
can't perform a search and look at
results and say well these are the best
results you really need to look at users
interactions to understand that okay so
what we really care about with search is
precision and recall I'm sure you're
mostly familiar with this concept I've
got this nice diagram so precision is
essentially out of all the results we
return for search how many are goods
I'm recall is our how many sites are
available all right okay our designer
made the slide that he's actually put
the same copy for both precision and
recourse yeah okay should have checked
that but yeah so basically recall is how
many how many return how many good
results you return out of all good
results precision is
okay let's get this one Punk yeah I
always get could be true not true
negatives false negative so sometimes
hard to remember but look up on
Wikipedia okay so let's talk about the
way the search is normally done says
thank you so it's this thing called BM
25 from the 80s I believe and that's
more or less what most out-of-the-box
search solutions are using now
essentially you look at the frequency of
you look at the terms in your search
query you look at the terms and all your
documents you're trying to match and you
say and then you look at the frequency
of those terms essentially so it's based
on tf-idf which is another acronym I can
never remember I just say T and F until
it sort of sounds right but yeah idea
turn frequency inverse document
frequency so for example if your query
contains a lot of your documents again
it contains the also so it ranks that
phrase downwards because every single
document might contain it so we know
it's not important whereas if we had a
term like Superman that's going to be in
very few documents I so those documents
which Superman is in should be relevant
to your search query so the problem of
this approach is that it's its lexical
so you're just basically doing string
matching on symbols you're saying well
this symbols here the symbols here so
it's probably relevant I think we've
seen expect from the history of AI that
these sort of approaches don't really
work they're not scalable because you
it's just rule and symbol based we're
trying to move away from that until I
more semantic type approaches that
you're seeing in deep learning so let me
show you a couple of things that go
wrong with this simple let's call proach
so here I've got a search for little
black dress and as humans even if we're
not fashion people I think we know the
little black dress is like a fashion
unit it's like a multi-word except
in particular to fashion it's a small
cocktail dress or a short cocktail dress
something like that but if you just use
the lexical approach and look at
individual symbols you don't get the
right results so you can see here the
first three results for little black
dress are actually matching a designer
called little little mistress which
isn't really the user intention but in
this algorithm we're saying well the
design of a product is very important so
let's rank designer matches very high
and here match in the designer is the
incorrect move likewise here's another
example so these are searching for red
Valentino and we're getting red products
that are by Valentino which sounds like
it's correct but the problem is that
Valentino have a sub brand called red
Valentino which is a different designer
and the user could also be searching for
that so these simple methods of just
string matching don't really work we
need to know more about the user
intention behind the search here's
another little one that's not strictly
related but if I showed you this I mean
what what would you think that was I
mean like my password a random string
this is actually a designer BCB that's
this area which I think the first time I
saw this I thought our autocomplete was
broken but this is a real designer and
people actually refer to this they don't
type it all out they refer to as BCBG
and likewise the designers like Saint
Laurent where that people refer to them
as YSL not the full words which is good
cuz I can't spell Saint Laurent but this
is another thing we need to think about
in searches ambiguities people shorten
things as nicknames that people use we
need to know all this and simple string
matching won't achieve that okay
one more example so here's three
products this one is a dress I think we
were all aware of that what do you think
the second product
has any ideas woke a bag is I'm sorry
the top product so it's actually a dress
shirt it's gives us a formal formal
shirt anyone guess what the third one is
we've got a dress a dress shirt and a
shirt dress and this is a real product
people search for listen well the
current search doesn't really work very
well for shirt dress we just get shirts
and dresses not shirt dresses so again
order matters and sin and if you use
something like bag of words where you
get rid of order which is most search
algorithms
it doesn't yeah you get this breaks okay
so what is a good result what is
relevancy in search it's good like I
said it's quite hard to determine the
most search algorithms aren't supervisor
anyway so it involves a lot of tuning of
parameters and sort of looking at the
results and going well this looks
alright so what you really need to do to
do search properly is get some labels
you need to know what is relevant for a
given term but that's quite tricky cuz
we have an infinite number of terms so
how do we get labels there's a couple of
ways the first thing easiest is click
through data click through data is
basically someone's on the site they
search for dress they click on a dress
so we assume that's a positive signal
that they search address in this product
is a good example of that there's a few
problems to click through data well it's
easy to collect that's a good advantage
it's free users of browsing the site
we've get laser click-through data but
there's a number of problems with it for
instance we don't get any negative data
so if user searches for something and
doesn't click anything we've got no
signals as to what is a good product for
that search term and likewise you've got
no idea about degrees of relevancy so if
you search for dress and click on 10
products we've got no idea which of
those 10 products is the most dressy out
of the clicks and also we don't get any
negative signals so for negative signals
we sort of have to make some assumptions
of
but if user didn't click a product then
you know we assume it's not relevant but
that might not be the case so the other
way to get good labels is with
crowdsourcing I could probably do a
whole presentation on crowdsourcing
because it's a really interesting area
because the people that you use are
actually quite unreliable so you've got
to help your crowdsourcing in a way that
combats that unreliability
for instance one thing we found is that
if you pay a person 3 pence to do one
item you you still get the same you
still get bad results you get better
results if you pay three people one
pence and take that average then you get
then it works out better than paying one
person more well the problem is like so
given a search phrase and results how
can we actually label those results so
here's one way we can do it we could use
an ordinal scale and say his search
phrase like pink heels please rank the
following products from one to five in
terms of how relevant they are to the
search phrase but this this doesn't work
very well because Pete it's very hard to
rank in the middle of a scale like one
it's very easy absolute doesn't match
five is very easy look they're like it
absolutely matches this perfect sample
but how about out of these products here
what rank would you give them they're
all sort of pink heels but they're
perhaps not perfectly pink heels like
one's a wedge ones multicolored what
rank do you actually give those so
instead we use this pairwise comparison
technique that we got from from a paper
called hipster Wars it's a really good
paper if you want to have a look at it
so the use of sectors of a blue trainers
we show them two products one I'd say
the one on that it's more blue is a
better example than the one that has
orange so then the user can say oh well
the blue one is better and that's an
easier decision for the crowdsource
moderator and then we can take all those
binary decisions and use something
called true skill to translate them into
a rank of which product is best for a
given search phrase so if every product
we represent it with a normal
distribution then we pair up prod
and for which and the product the user
clicks we update the parameters of the
distribution and the variance gets lower
the mean goes higher and we keep doing
this multiple times until we build up a
complete ranking of all products and the
rank is basically the mean of the
distribution minus some something times
the variance and the higher you multiply
the variance the more that you're saying
you're penalizing the rank based on the
unknown variance yeah so we do that lots
lots of times for many search phrases
and then we have yeah rankings for every
search phrase and we can train a model
so the way that we pick the search
phrases is we just looked all our search
phrases and sort of did a greedy
algorithm to replace the terms in the
search phrases with like what we call
templates so you can see here that the
most popular searches design above plus
category which is basically like as
sandals or Gucci dress that's what most
users searching for we built a list of
say 20 of these templates sampled search
phrase from all the templates sampled
products from all the search phrases and
then did crowdsourcing on them and the
way that we sample products is we use
existing rank in our search which is
just BM 25 and sample products from
percentiles and the results so that we
have bad products and good products and
then the users will read the moderators
will rewrite them for us and we found
that we re ranking actually works so we
could see products initially at the
bottom of a results got moved to the top
and product so a top got moved to the
button by the moderators so now we've
got some data on what is relevant how
can we use that to make a better search
algorithm so here's a model again from
Microsoft this is like a deep neural
network and what we do is put in a query
into this neural network and some
products or documents and one of the
products is relevant to search query as
as predicted by our
crowd sourcing and some products are not
and the idea is that the model will
maximize the probability that the
relevant document will be returned for
the query and the Unreal event documents
by nice how it works basically and one
of the nice little tricks I use for this
is something called trigram hashing so
instead of using back of words or mass
effectors we just look at all the
trigram frequencies in the documents and
phrases and it gives that it reduces the
dimensionality of the input which is
nice and it gives us some nice things
like more morphologic in variant so you
might have something like I don't dress
and dresses but they both contain the
same trigram internally so we get round
having to worry about pluralization and
that sort of thing and it also helps out
of vocabulary problems so instead of
saying each words is you know we have a
coefficient for each word we just do
trigram so once we get unseen words we
can decompose them into their trigrams
and we know something about them rather
than not knowing anything about them so
this is a simple model and then we're
actually working with a deep learning
researcher who worked on this model and
this is a updates DSM to have a
convolutional max pooling layer and what
this gives us while the max pooling
layer basically lets us drop unimportant
features which is really valuable so say
like the word isn't very useful we don't
really need to know about that trigram
usually so max pooling will drop that
from our feature set for us and the
convolutional layer basic gives us like
supervised contextual feature detectors
and from his paper it shows the results
are better than not using convolutional
layers to here's some results these are
our results these are actually from the
paper we haven't quite finished
implementing this yet so you search for
Microsoft Office and you can see that
the top ranked results are all related
to Microsoft Office whereas the bottom
ranked results are related to things
like like physical offices so the
representation that we're learning in
this model it can has a semantic power
to distinguish between the meaning of
words depending on the context they
occur in and the same for car Body Shop
the first hit is car body kit which
sounds good and the bottom here is force
field body armor don't know who so it
does what we want it to do I'll just
talk a little bit about how we actually
deploy this thing so to actually do this
search quickly we pre calculate all the
representations for every product we
just take the hidden layer of our model
store it in a Postgres database and then
we have a little C module that does very
fast searching over that over those
representations using artificial neural
networks previously to this use elastic
search and our queries were taking like
500 milliseconds to a second answer
which is way too slow for search and
using this method with Postgres we're
doing it in about 50 milliseconds and we
started using this for basically all our
machine learning infrastructure list so
something else we can do with our deep
learning model we can try to include
images which will give us a lot more
power so for example with a little black
dress example many products won't say I
am a little black dress but if a few
products do and those products have
images that are similar to other
products we can start matching more or
more by using the image information so
we trained another deep convolutional
network based on alex nap it's eight
layers deep there's about 60 million
parameters we train this on a on a big
GPU server and the nice thing that we do
is we have lots of fields were
interested and we're interested in
things like gender and color and
category and all these properties of a
fashion product so we want to build an
image representation that can represent
all these different fields so we
optimize the network for predicting
color then we basically swap
part of the network keep the
representation and then optimize for
type or something like that and then we
build up this robust representation that
knows about all the properties of
products that were interested in yeah
and it takes up through the ages is
about six hours per iteration this takes
to train and needs about thirty
iterations yeah so this is it working so
we put in an image and it predicts the
color the gender what we call the type
and category yeah she gets it slightly
wrong here it says it's a three-piece
suit when it's a two-piece suit but we
have very few suits and lists so it's
not the best example to show but you can
see the print mostly predicts everything
correctly so we can say our
representation is quite good yeah so a
so on gender and color it gets something
like 90 to 99 percent accuracy wears on
the category it's about 85% accurate
yeah so another thing we did with this
representation just have a look at if it
is good we take the representation you
can reduce your dimensionality to two
dimensions so we can plot it and what
you see here is a random selection of
products in in the two dimensions based
on the representation that we've learned
in the convolutional neural network and
it's got some interesting little
properties so if we zoom in you can see
the sort of clusters all the shirts
together this is like a little shirt
peninsula in the representation space so
is learning about similarity between the
images oh we go somewhere else you can
see this sort of a little shoe island
there and there's some some model shots
and if you play about you can see it's
roughly classifying the right thing you
get color groups you get pictures with
models then you get pictures of shoes
that picture on the side or from the top
and it does seem to be understanding
what we need so the next step for us is
to incorporate this into our current
search model along with the textual
search and then hopefully we'll have a
world-class search so thank you so in
agent search is fun but it's very hard
and I think it's a topic that people are
looking out as much as other topics such
as recommendations so I think as a
community we should start talking about
a bit more Thanks